if you have a trans woman that is
biologically male and has a penis but is
slight in size and has a very feminine
appearance
by all
statistical likelihood they are far less
likely to assault someone in a women's
prison than they are to be assaulted in
a men's prison and so that's a
particular case where i would say it
makes sense for them to be in a women's
prison yes
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is the
progressive commentator and the host of
the david pakman show right here on
youtube david pakman welcome to
trigonometry thank you for having me
uh it's so great to have you on the show
listen we'll get right into it and i'll
say this for our audience what i've
already said to you off camera which is
we're really grateful to you for coming
on the show uh we want to have a
constructive conversation with you and i
really acknowledge you for coming on our
show because i think a lot of people who
are progressive might think that you
know francis and i are these two
right-wing nut jobs which we're
definitely not and we're really keen
actually to hear some of your thoughts
and why you think what you think so very
much with that in mind if did i describe
you correctly as a progressive
commentator is that a fair fair way to
describe you that's how i describe
myself as a sort of uh standard
progressive in the northern european
mold
there are people who say i am a
communist socialist and i'm definitely
not there are people who say i'm a
centrist establishment shill which i'm
definitely not i'm just
uncontroversially sort of like a
northern european social democrat right
so what does that mean exactly what do
you want
so th this is a form of capitalism right
so strictly speaking if we if we start
with a sort of just black white
is my view of you that it falls under
capitalism the answer is yes and social
democracy is a well-regulated form of
capitalism where we say
there's lots of good things about
capitalism and about markets directing
resources in many areas but there are
some what we would call special cases
and these might depending on who you ask
include health care they might include
education and other what we call public
goods and in those cases we don't want
to let
the free market or a supposedly free
market as is often the case
direct resources and in order to fund
those public goods we would use taxes
you're still allowed to make a ton of
money you can still become very wealthy
but
we would use
some of the
top wealth to say let's fund these
special areas that we would say as are
exceptions to free market capitalism
things like healthcare for example which
is pretty much what we do here in
britain i find that all entirely
uncontroversial i think where some of
the controversies might start to come in
as the cultural side what does it mean
to be culturally progressive well i
think one of the issues is
that
these are not necessarily major issues
for folks like me and so one of the
things i try to do
is um
not
delve too deeply into
opining about
positions where defending positions
which are not mine so i guess what i
want to say is
there's a lot of what i believe are
fabricated culture wars i can speak to
the united states and because that's
where my knowledge is in the united
states there have been uh in the absence
of policy for what i call the american
right wing which includes the republican
party but it also includes right-wing
people who don't really care about the
republican party many trumpists were
never voters before trump so it doesn't
have to be republicans but the american
right wing has given up on policy they
don't really talk about taxes anymore
they don't really talk about immigration
reform
they take a cultural approach
and part of that is framing the left as
being obsessed with identity politics
and all these different things these
things exist on the left they're not
really my cup of tea and so i don't have
a huge interest in defending some of
those aspects for me i have cultural
views uh but they're not the primary um
sort of uh
element of my politics do you mind if i
ask you what they are though
sure i mean
give me a question about a particular
issue and i'll give you my opinion okay
i i've been talking for too long i'll
let francis ask some questions and then
we'll come back to the culture side of
that uh okay so
let's look at so
we're looking at economics let's let's
look let's really delve into into the
economics of it so
what would you say when it comes to a
fair amount to tax an individual
what is your opinion on that an
individual of what income
and so oh that that's a good question so
for instance in the uk i think over 50
if you earn over 50 000 a year sterling
you get taxed 40
which i think is too high
personally and i think if you're taxed
over 100k then you get 50 percent
which is a very high taxation rate and
if the effect of taxes probably even
higher yeah
so i can so in the united states uh
there's the federal taxes
and then some states have a state income
tax some don't
um
my view first of all before we even talk
about changing the tax rates is that tax
money is dramatically misallocated in
the u.s so i think the u.s spends way
too much on military and defense there
are guaranteed contracts given where we
just replace weapon unused weapons
they're sort of given like an expiration
date and then the government just keeps
buying and buying uh the tentacles of
military bases around the world to me is
totally overblown for the safety and
security of the united states so before
even talking about changing the current
tax rates
i think that money that's already coming
in should be used in a very different
way and maybe you wouldn't even need to
change tax rates at all
now if
changes were to be made to tax rates um
i would like to see some higher brackets
created right now the top tax bracket in
the u.s starts i actually don't have the
numbers in front of me but it's around
half a million dollars a year in income
to me the difference between someone
making five hundred thousand dollars a
year
five million dollars a year and a
billion dollars a year is very different
and so i think we need more tax rates
and you know maybe it would be
at two million dollars a year right now
the top tax rate's 37 just for context
so you guys know
maybe uh at 2 million bucks a year you
go to 39
and maybe at 20 million bucks a year you
go to 42 i mean you know i'm not in the
mindset of we need a 90 top tax rate or
anything like that i just think we need
some higher brackets because what you
have in the us is that the very very
richest not the one percent not the 0.5
percent but like the point one percent
pay a lower effective tax rate than
people who earn less that doesn't seem
right but um again you know but there
might be the belief that people like me
are talking about 60 70 tax rates i'm
not talking about that
okay and that's a great answer because
sometimes i think people on the right
mischaracterize the left as and you know
there will be people on the left who are
like this who are just like all rich
people are evil they need to have all
their wealth taken away from them
and obviously that's a
mischaracterization
where do you stand
on
uh the democrats and people and that
political party would you say that
you're pro-democrat or are you one of
those people on the left like we've had
a lot of them on like the aramaites the
jimmy dawgs who are very very
distrustful of the democrats and
actually in many cases see them as worse
than the republicans so if it's with
respect i will give my views in the
absence of a comparison to the
individuals you just listed is that fair
i have never been a registered democrat
i don't really care about political
parties beyond
i will be glad to vote for democrats if
they're the better option in a
particular election so in 2020 the
options were trump and biden
biden was the better option
and he happened to be a democrat and i
voted for him but my view about
political parties is they are
essentially like a corporation that
wants to justify its own existence part
of the way that they justify their own
existence is in opposition or in
contrast to the other party certainly i
i the politics of the democratic party
are much closer to mine than the
republican party but i i don't really
care about the democratic party as an
institution
and what do you make of populism and the
rise of populism do you see that as a
problem which i do and this is i i mean
i don't know where i would identify
myself now but this is prob this is my
opinion i think a lot of populism was
created
by the left by the more progressive
elements of left-wing politics and
politicians essentially turning their
back on working-class people and not
representing them certainly in my own
country in the uk with the labour party
so i completely disagree with that
analysis as applied to the united states
but
um the problem i have with populism
is that populism fundamentally is
rhetoric more than it is policy and so
when i talk about social democracy
without explaining policy
there's a pretty well established set of
policies that go along with that some of
which i might agree with in some of
which i might disagree with and what
works in sweden may not work in denmark
or might work in the united states or it
might not the the pernicious part for me
about populism is that it's
fundamentally a rhetoric
and rhetoric particularly in a country
with such educational problems as the
united states such lack of media
literacy and critical thinking can be
used by bad actors to convince people to
support really bad candidates trump used
a version of populist rhetoric he was
china's screwing us the working class
i'm going to fix it etcetera the problem
with populist rhetoric absent of really
clear vision of policy is that you put
in someone
into power based on their rhetoric and
all of a sudden the solutions they
propose are wacky like for example
tucker carlson is a propagandist on fox
news
who uh uses populist rhetoric
but all of a sudden when you say well
what's a solution um well
you've got to prevent antifa from taking
your house or brown people from mexico
are taking your job and we've got to
stop that so a lot of the same rhetoric
we hear from the left and right that
sounds populist is used in different
ways and so for me i take more of a
policy oriented approach of social
democracy and i'm not big on uh populist
rhetoric myself
okay well uh before i come to the
cultural stuff and maybe the immigration
point you make as well you mentioned
that you thought that joe biden was the
better option at the last election yeah
uh
what have you liked about uh the biden
administration and are you still of the
view that that was the right choice in
terms of voting for biden the two
from the two options it was the right
choice i mean to to speak candidly with
you gentlemen
donald trump was a humiliating
embarrassment i mean just the
the promises he made
none of them were kept you know he was
going to build a wall he didn't build it
he was going to
solve the israeli-palestinian conflict
jared actually was going to solve it his
son-in-law as you know it hasn't been
solved he was i mean there was a look
there was a lot of progress on that
would you concede that
i don't well what progress was there the
well the israeli foreign minister
turning up in saudi arabia i mean all of
that stuff and better relations between
the countries in the region did you not
feel that that was some progress what
changed materially though
uh
look but maybe let's not spend too much
time on it so you did anything
let me put it this way did anything
change materially
i think it's quite a difficult situation
to change material in the course of a
four-year presidency but so it didn't
that's fair okay we agree it didn't
change materially they did do some
optics things you know there was a
flight like from tel aviv to uae but i
think we're on the same page we can't
neither one of us can identify anything
that changed materially is that fair
um i i what i would say is
i think some progress was made in a very
difficult situation i don't claim that
the situation became
dramatically different and we are now
like way way towards a solution and also
i think i'd also consider it's not an
issue i know enough about to have a
proper discussion with you as well
that's fair let's let's we'll we can
table it on that on that basis um no
listen i mean as far as joe biden joe
biden's not exciting to me you know i'm
a progressive social democrat so joe
biden's not exciting he did some good
things so he did a third covet stimulus
at a time that i think it was necessary
extended a pause on student loans got a
pretty good infrastructure bill passed
got us out of afghanistan which i think
was a great thing i think that that was
a quagmire
but be oh yeah oh my god i mean we were
there i agree with you with the quagmire
point but did you feel that the way that
was done went well
i think it went as well as it would have
gone no matter who did it
wow
interesting i mean when asked trump was
asked what would you have done
differently
and he literally couldn't articulate a
single difference so at least
trump was going to do it and he another
failed promise
biden did it and when trump was given
the opportunity to articulate how he
would have handled it differently
he couldn't name a single difference so
let me in the most factual way possible
i've not heard
trump
explain what would have gone differently
and therefore i have no basis on which
to assume it would have is that fair
i suppose it is i su the question for me
is i i
i mean
i struggle to imagine it going any worse
so
i kind of feel like there is a
possibility that the preparations could
have gone better is that do you think
that's unfair i have a struggle to
imagine it could have gone better so
like i think where i land is it went the
way i expected you know and and it was
correct ultimately to get out okay pl
please carry on i'll interrupt you
um
bye you're talking about whether you're
happy with the biden presence yeah i
mean it's like listen um
he's doing exactly what i expected you
know i didn't expect him to do anything
on cannabis decriminalization and he's
not and i didn't expect any at least in
the first two years immigration reform
and we're not getting it so you know my
i try not to become jaded or cynical but
basically i i've seen from biden exactly
what i expected okay
you mentioned trump being a humiliation
and look uh uh you know neither francis
or i were pro-trump um i thought was
good i thought he raised some important
issues by the way uh you know an
immigration not not not being least of
those we can have a conversation about
that maybe later on but um
if if trump was a humiliation perhaps in
the way that he talked and you you
mentioned some of the promises that he
didn't deliver on
the optics of the biden president
presidency do they do they not make you
cringe somewhat when he's shaking hands
in mid-air with people who aren't there
and forgetting things and and all of
that
beautiful so are you guys open to a good
faith conversation about that absolutely
okay absolutely okay so let's go piece
by piece
um does joe biden sometimes lose his
train of thought absolutely
absolutely there's no question about it
and he's close to 80 years old if you
compare joe biden today to joe biden
when he ran circles around paul ryan in
2012 it's not the same guy i have no
problem saying that that's absolutely
the case
no argument whatsoever
the shaking hands with mid-air video was
a total joke and i'll tell you the story
about it the weekend that that story you
know the shaking hands with midair
i looked at the clip on my phone and it
was a very short clip where you just see
biden stop speaking he turns to the side
and he goes like this
i said oh my goodness this is this is
terrible biden he seems worse than trump
when trump came off of his plane
and his car was right in front of him
and trump wandered off and was brought
back by the arm by a secret service
agent and they said here's your car that
lit that's worse than when trump had
rudy giuliani sitting right across the
table and said
where where's
rudy and maybe i'll ask rudy to say a
few words
well thanks
thank you very very much mr president
first of all congratulations on
what is in fact a historic uh start of
an administration i've never seen so
much done
in so short a period of time
this but that biden clip looked that
um and i was going to report like guys
this something seems wrong with joe
biden and then i found like a the actual
full
frame instead of the square twitter
video
and you could see what happened after
and joe biden had people to his right
and to his back right and to his back
and and he literally finished the speech
and turned and said something to the
people to the right and then he turns
back and he does the exact same thing
and then to the other side and does the
exact same thing so
that was
a non-story for me it was a completeness
i hear you yeah david i'll i haven't
done enough research and i'll admit it
readily that i don't know whether that's
accurate but i'm happy for the purpose
of this discussion to accept that fair
but would you accept that joe biden
mentally is not at his peak i think you
already have i already have yeah
so is is that not a humiliation
well when i say a humiliation i go by
what is global opinion of the united
states
that's my because i'm one guy right and
so yeah what what is so i want to say
what does the world think
and we know because of global gallup
studies and global pew studies and
others
that opinion of the united states as an
as a country
of the us's ability to lead
of the president of the united states it
was in the toilet to use a phrase trump
likes you know to flush 10 or 15 times
opinion was in the toilet under trump
and it has recovered dramatically under
biden so i try to take myself out of it
and just say what does the world think
and there's a couple of exceptions
russia liked trump better than biden
again this is not
rhetorical it's just the opinion polls
russia did like trump better than biden
i think turkey liked trump better than
biden
and for some this may be wrong but i
think i have nigeria in my mind liked
trump better than biden but other than
that empirically
our global reputation has recovered
dramatically under biden so that's my
standard that i use
hey constantine do you like shopping no
in russia you skin bear with your bare
hands and wear it obviously this is for
men only women and small children are
allowed to use knife where did you get
your blazer from it's made out of bear
babushka created it for me using nothing
but her own bare hands no pun intended
i wondered what the smell was but for
those of you who do want an easy no
hassle solution to the grind of going
shopping then stitch fix is for you
stitch fix is a service for both men and
women and make shopping for clothes easy
to get started go to stitch fix dot co
dot uk forward slash trigger to set up
your profile they'll deliver clothes
chosen just for you in your taste size
and budget and by taste they mean
something that will look good instead of
showing the world you're having a
mid-life crisis like me the items you
buy arrive at your door a few days later
you try everything on at home decide
what to keep and then send anything else
back it's so easy you just pay 10 pounds
each time you order which is credited
towards the items you keep and you'll
get 20 off when you keep all five items
there's no subscription plus shipping
returns and exchanges are easy and free
stitch fix does the hard work for you
making shopping for clubs easy and
hassle free get started today at
stitchfix dot co dot uk forward slash
trigger and get 20 off when you keep all
five items can you order fresh siberian
bear skin from stitch fix
possibly go to stitch fix dot co dot uk
forward slash trigger to find out
and do not think that
the problem
with trump trump was never the problem
he was a symptom of the problem which is
a large part of the working classes and
the ross belt in particular felt
alienated by the democrats they felt
they weren't being represented by them
and that's why they voted which shows
that there is a real problem
amongst that part of the left that they
can't connect with the working classes
because the working classes don't feel
that they have their best interests at
heart
so i would say a couple different things
i would say there is absolutely a
problem with the democratic party that
it is not
doing enough for the working class i
again i'm not a democrat i don't care
about the party i gladly concede that
what i see as the problem with trump
is more
i agree with the idea that trump was a
symptom rather than the problem
but for me the problem was if trump
doesn't have people who fall for his
obviously false promises and complete
lack of understanding of any issue
if people don't fall for that trump's
the crazy guy yelling in the new york
subway right the danger comes from the
fact that in the united states there are
so many people who are either
not engaged with politics at all that
when a celebrity pops up they go that
sounds kind of good i know who trump is
or they're so
um they lack knowledge of issues to such
a degree
that when they hear trump say i'm going
to fix trade
by putting tariffs on china and nobody
trump doesn't even understand that it's
american companies that pay the tariffs
and all trump starts saying look at how
much we charge china and then his
followers go we charge china so much and
it's like guys
it's the american companies that pay the
tariffs so when people don't understand
stuff they fall for people like trump
and that to me is the problem because
without the cult members you don't
become a cult leader you need followers
to be a cult leader and so i agree with
you that trump is emblematic
as a symptom rather than actually being
the problem but my perspective is a
little bit different as to why
david can i uh
in the spirit of a very good faith but
honest conversation
can i feed back to you what it sounds
like you just said from where i'm
sitting yes which is francis was saying
to you there's a large portion of the
american public who are so alienated by
some of the rhetoric on the left that
they they went
to they had to resort to voting for
donald trump that's his argument and
what you said is no that that isn't
really the problem the problem is
americans are ill-educated and quite
stupid and full for for trump's
bombastic statements that's what it
sounds like did i hear you right it's a
combination of both
okay now but here's one thing but isn't
that sorry david just to finish this
point isn't that always the case though
i mean it's not like the public got
massively more stupid and ill-educated
in the last four years right or the last
six years so well
i don't know
i don't know about that i mean i don't
know how much you follow american
education
but i think
let me put it this way it's beyond me
to
deeply dive into that specific niche of
this discussion but i think there are
many who would make the case that
actually
the american public on average has
become less educated over time
okay
let's i don't want to argue with that
but wouldn't wouldn't you accept that
these movements these right-wing
populist movements we also had this here
in the uk with brexit and uh it's an
issue that probably you i i don't want
to assume but you may know less about it
than we do and certainly we would say in
this country that
the same arguments were made these are
stupid racists whatever people but
actually if you speak to a lot of people
who voted this way which we didn't
neither of us did but if you speak to
those people their concerns uh were not
based around ill education or or
whatever but it was uh there were some
issues that they were raising that were
not being reflected in the public debate
that were dismissed and uh certainly
from our perspective it seemed like
there there were some parallels with the
united states so it's not that people
got more stupid or less educated it's
more that their concerns were being more
and more ignored by the left-wing
parties and they were desperate for some
kind of way out which is why they voted
for brexit and which is why they voted
for trump that's absolutely valid and i
have no qualms with that that's what
took place i think the reason i'm has
skeptical to accept that the reason for
trump was
that democrats have abandoned the middle
class is that more democrats crossed
party lines to vote for john mccain in
2008
than the number that crossed party lines
to vote for trump in 2016. and so
i hesitate to say that that was the
particular reason
because the numbers don't bear it out
okay sorry to interrupt but the thing is
you said yourself what trump did and
what brexit did is it brought a lot of
non-voters out of the shadows if you
like so exactly so what what actually
happened is these people who stopped
voting for the democrats and for labor
years and years ago because they felt
like these parties stopped representing
them we have a labour party here in the
uk that stopped representing working
people they would argue a long long time
ago and finally a movement came along
that actually represented them so it's
not the mccain democrats we're talking
about here we're talking about people
who are non-voters for decades perhaps
who are now back in the fold because
they're finally seeing someone represent
their views that's the argument
so
that's an empirical question which i
don't have the data in front of me to
say i've not seen any data that suggests
that
years inactive democrats are who came
out to vote for trump that's it's you're
making that assertion i can't deny that
that happened i've just seen no evidence
and unfortunately without the data it's
hard to engage with it any further
okay so that's fair enough to david
what do you think as a as a person or as
on the left when it comes to
globalization
because in many ways you could argue
that globalization is a positive you
know we get things goods cheaper etc etc
but also as well
it means that we don't produce enough at
home we've lost our manufacturing bases
you know and that means that you then
have towns which become disenfranchised
because they have no factories
manufacturing etc etc and then creates
the types of areas that will vote for a
right-wing populist such as trump
yeah i'm
i i
am basically with you 95
of with what you just said the last
piece and it logically leads to people
voting for trump let's put that aside
for for now at least and maybe we can
come back to that so my view on
globalization is as follows you know
generally speaking uh i am in favor of
specialization you know at a basic
economics macroeconomic level i
understand the reason why we would uh
have circumstances where
one country doesn't just produce
everything you know we there's trade i
believe trade is a net positive i
believe specialization is a net positive
i think the problem i have with a lot of
the conversation about domestic versus
um import when it comes to a number of
different products services industries
is that there's a sort of naivete where
both republicans and democrats in the
united states love to say we're going to
bring it back home it's going to be made
in the usa we're going to bring it here
we're going to be independent this type
of thing
and the the truth is that
through cumulative economic policy
decisions over 30 or even 40 years
dating back to you know ronald reagan
the united states has
chosen and i mean chosen again not one
one person didn't decide this but the
cumulative effect of decisions has been
we would rather
get stuff from other countries and be
able to buy it for less in the united
states rather than
manufacturing here and maybe this would
create some jobs but everything would be
a lot more money so i often say you know
cheap tchotchkes from china are a really
important thing in the american economy
and so when trump would say we're gonna
make it all domestically or when biden
says we're gonna make it all
domestically number one these are like
multi-decade projects to to change
supply chains on a lot of these things
and
there's not sort of like a just upfront
thing where like everything's going to
cost more
and most americans don't want that
because you know half of americans can't
afford an unexpected 400 expense so
i'm totally fine with the basic
framework that even if you just account
for geographical and climate differences
like your most countries can't produce
everything
and
the honesty that i wish were part that's
missing that i wish were part of the
discussion is
we can start bringing supply chains back
home and isolating etc but everything
will get way more expensive and then
whoever's in power will get blamed for
that too
yeah it's you're never going to get a
simple solution to a very complex
problem but don't you think
what happened
when uh with and look it depends where
you stand on whether the virus was
created in a lab in wuharnam
all of that and the answer it might be
that when you don't agree with that well
i'm just saying
do we have any evidence that it was
created in a lab right now
i mean there are some people who believe
very credible there's very people who
believe the earth is flat what i'm
saying is do we have evidence that that
is the case
uh we have a very prominent scientist
scientist saying that that's the case
but let's not have this argument i'm i'm
just to allow that to be placed as an
aside you know okay we hear that you
disagree with that assertion can we yeah
yeah yeah so so but what i was saying
was
the fact that if you have people
who
you are in hot to or produce like for
instance with china they produce a huge
amount of antibiotics do you not do not
think that it would be better from a
security point of view to then have that
back in the united states for example or
to have that with countries who you are
allied to
i'm completely uh sensitive to that
logic that that in many ways that's
perfectly logical yeah
okay okay uh i think you must also have
to be honest about the effect it could
have on price oh sure it's gonna cost
more but sometimes you have to pay more
for security i mean i don't disagree
look at germany and russian gas right
now and again don't need to get into
that yeah so david let's talk about
culture i know that it's not necessarily
a big thing for you
but in terms of some of the things we've
been putting to you that we are
sensitive to which is how culture
affects how people feel about their
country about the party that they want
to vote for about the direction of
travel of their society i would probably
chart three issues on which
a lot of people in our space which is
perhaps disaffected lefties or people
who are sort of centrists like me or
people who are right-leaning
that have been concerned about
and feel are important and are not being
discussed honestly in in the mainstream
space let's say right i think number one
certainly in the uk you tell me what you
think about the united states but is
number one is immigration
number two is race relations
and all the stuff to do with blm and all
of that and number three as of late
these sort of big toxic issues is of
course the trans issue
okay so
sure those are three issues yes yeah
yeah
i was going somewhere with i just wanted
to get confirmation those are issues
that exist absolutely those are issues
that exist and what i am asserting to
you is there are quite a lot of people
uh certainly here in the uk uh and i
know that in america it's it's the same
in some circles that feel very strongly
about those issues and they feel that
the mainstream conversation about those
issues is dishonest so if we start in
reverse order with the trans thing
can i can i it's a dick move to ask you
this but can i ask you to define a woman
is that okay yeah so listen i mean i did
a whole thing with this right-wing guy
named michael knowles a little while ago
okay
you know we were talking about the
definition of a woman and the context
was
um the katanji brown jackson hearings
and her refusal to answer and there i
argued that makes perfect sense because
they're asking in a legal context the
question is who can bring a
discrimination lawsuit on the basis of
gender and i thought she was right not
to answer it and i made the point that
depending on where you're asking the
question the answer could actually be
different now i'm glad to give my view
of this socially if that's okay sure
yeah of course so this is again and the
problem with this and i know you guys
would never do this because you seem so
honest the problem is that sometimes
this question is then used to put
someone in a corner so i will say in
advance that the definition i have will
not work in every setting okay like for
example the definition i have in an ob
gyn's office may not work because we
recognize biological differences right
but for me
the broadest way where i think about
who am i going to relate to as a woman
it would be somebody
who i identify
as deliberately
trying to exist in the world as a woman
and so okay if i see a biological man
who
and again we we have to talk about this
in candid ways which some people might
not like but i think it's necessary if i
see if if i see me
with a wig on
it's not going to be apparent to me that
that's someone who is necessarily trying
to exist in the world as a woman if they
go by the name david and their their
voices like mine and they dress like me
so i'm just going to make the best faith
effort i can where if it's if it's
indicated through a number of different
cues that someone is trying to exist in
the world as a woman i'll relate to them
as a woman that's fine it just doesn't
bother me oh sure and in fact i am kind
of where you are in the sense that we've
had a [ __ ] ton of trans people on the
show and we call them by whatever name
they have and the pronouns that they
they've chosen right i've got no issue
with that however
my issue is that in
and again decision being straight with
you i hope you don't take offense to
what i'm saying please in your in your
refusal to to give a definition that is
equally applicable in different
circumstances
you're kind of avoiding the difficult
elements of this right well the
difficult elements are the exactly that
which if okay i'm sorry i interrupted
let me i know you know where i'm going
but let me just give the example so
people know what we're talking about so
we have a a number of cases here in the
uk for example and i know you've had
some in the us as well where a trans
woman who still has a male anatomy has
been housed in a female prison and has
gone on to commit sexual assault against
women in prison right okay we obviously
have had uh trans women in male sport in
female sports where they in my opinion
have an unfair advantage uh and there
are other situations in which our
failure to give a clear like universal
definition means that women in
particular in this very instance are
suffering the consequences of our social
unwillingness to be quite hardline about
it would you agree with that well
there's that's that's what in in a in a
court they would say that that's a
compound question and we've really got
to break down each of those because
whether i agree with everything you said
i don't know
so let's let's i'm not even sure where
to start so um okay i mean in prison
there was a sexual assault by a
biological male housed with women okay i
don't know the story
we have a country of 331 million in the
united states so you can find examples
sort of of everything um
sexual assault by biological females of
other females in american prisons is
really common so for me
what i go to is less about you know
trans people i think are one-third of
one percent of the population in the us
i i may be slightly off about that but
let's use that as a working number
for me
every assault is bad and the bigger
issue is american prisons are terrible
at keeping inmates safe and i apply that
to men's prisons and women's prisons
but but you're deflecting here aren't
you i don't well but no i don't think so
but let me let me go first let me give
you the reverse of your argument right
no but well
it wasn't even shooting black people is
is bad but the real problem is something
else and we shouldn't talk about the
cops shooting black people no
that's not the argument i'm making okay
sure go ahead sorry so the the point
that i'm making is
no because that what you're saying is
it's i guess it depends on what you say
the other issue really is that you
didn't get to the end of that and so
that's the right wing argument black on
black crime is the real thing forget
about cub shooting black people right
those are totally different things what
i'm saying is
violence in prison is a major problem
and i don't deny that an added layer of
complexity is yeah in which prison
should
a trans person be i don't pretend to
have the answer in all cases i don't
pretend to have the answer i'm conceding
it's very complicated
is it complicated if you have a penis
should you be in a female prison
well but not everybody who's a trans
woman has a penis but these people did
and they were in female prisons both in
your country in an hour i i just don't
know the case i don't know i don't know
the answer
should a person with a penis though be
in a in a female prison it's it's i
would have to know more about how these
decisions are being made i don't know
enough about how the decisions are made
to be able to say
so i mean listen let me put it let me
put it a different way let me put it a
different way
and i i don't know if anecdotes
were both being so anecdotal that i
don't know if this is even useful but
there are there are many instances
where i could show you
a picture of someone and describe their
height and weight to you
and
it would be very hard to argue that they
should be
in a men's prison for their own safety
i'm not arguing for that
we've had trans people on the show who
say we need to make provisions so that
trans people
are in a separate facility where they're
going to be safe from males who
otherwise would potentially be a danger
to them right transformation is a third
prison for trans people that's what some
people have argued on our shows i'm not
saying you take someone who identifies
as a trans woman and you stick them with
men because i don't think it would end
well for them so i don't lack compassion
what i'm trying to get out with you is
do you envisage circumstances under
which it is right to put a person with a
penis in a female prison
uh i can i can envisage uh theoretical
circumstances where it's the best of the
options that are available yeah i mean
right now there are no third prisons for
trans people and so if you say to me
what is more like i mean like listen
let's just be very up front if you have
if you have a trans woman that is
biologically male and has a penis
but is slight in size and has a very
feminine appearance
by all
statistical likelihood they are far less
likely to assault someone in a women's
prison than they are to be assaulted in
a men's prison and so that's a
particular case where i would say it
makes sense for them to be in a women's
prison yes
okay
we could go we could go around for hours
but look
before we move on in the situation i
outlined do you concede that it makes
more sense for them to be in the if the
only two options are a men's or women's
prison would a 5-3 biological male with
a penis who is outwardly feminine and
and is seen by the average person as a
woman you're not going to put them in
the men's prison are you i think it'd be
very dangerous to do so fair so we agree
on that that's fair well well we don't
agree on that because i don't think
either of those options is acceptable
and we should look for a solution rather
than going i would love another solution
but it seems like we want to give them
the two current options we are on the
same page
uh
no i i just think both of those options
are completely unacceptable to me and i
think we need a third solution and
that's why i feel strongly about it do
you see what i'm saying i see what
you're saying i but it sounds like
before you realized it might not look
great to concede it that you agreed in
the two options we have now the female
prison makes more sense
uh i think this is why i'm gonna do it
david pakman and go i think it depends
on the individual circumstances
if this person is in prison because of
sexual assault against women i i don't
know that that is the right choice
personally okay i mean maybe in that
case they would be we're now getting so
in the weeds but yeah that's the case
that's why they might be they might be
in solitary confinement anyway in that
situation as i mean we now we're really
getting too narrow i think
sure yeah
hey kkk do you believe in spring
cleaning yes but only when my wife does
it in russia men who clean are executed
for not being real men which is correct
well for those men who are living in the
21st century manscaped has an incredible
offer for you manscaped are the global
leaders immense below the ways grooming
and have forever changed the grooming
game with their amazing performance
package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
the lawn mower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop provider turner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your werewolves might look like
a couple of boris johnsons treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
by the way mate it's father's day around
the corner get me a present because i am
the daddy of trigonometry how about i
get your lawnmower 4.0 for when your
girlfriend dumps you why would i need
one because standards have changed since
we were last on the dating scene once
upon a time you could have a forest
grown down there but it's 2022 and
deforestation is the order of the day
personal grooming isn't just for the
younger man get 20 off and free shipping
with the code trigger20 at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code trigger20 at manscape.com
it's time to throw out all your old
hygiene habits and upgrade your life
can i just say david i'm really enjoying
this conversation yeah because i'm doing
all the hard questioning that's why
you're [ __ ] enjoying it
but let's go on to a very thorny issue
my girlfriend is a left-wing progressive
uh you know woman of color and all the
rest of it and her and i have
regular ding-dongs about this
at least twice a week which is the
thorny topic of immigration
and i am pro limiting immigration
because my argument comes from actually
a very left-wing perspective which is
super demand and supply so for instance
i remember one of my flatmates when i
was in my late twenties uh was a mixed
race guy called daniel and daniel used
to vote ukip which was a populist
right wing of the conservatives
essentially and i said to him dan like
your mixed race why are you voting for
ukip and he said francis because i'm an
electrician right
and ever since freedom of movement in
the european union i've seen my wages
frozen because people come from all over
the european union to come and work in
london now i've got nothing against
those people and in fact if i was in
their position i would do exactly the
same but the effect for me is that my
wages haven't risen in real time because
there's so much competition because
london is the place they all come to so
by
limiting immigration
limiting the amount of people who can
come and work in my field my wages will
therefore rise as a result and i
personally couldn't think of a counter
argument
to that particular point
and your question to me is
and my question to you is you know where
do you stand on immigration and do you
have sympathy for that position because
a lot of people on the left and i'm not
saying that you think this would go oh
you know and they mischaracterize it as
foreigners coming over here and taking
our jobs when i think we can both agree
it's more complex it's more complex so
again i can speak to the united states
i've studied immigration
pretty deeply here so the first thing is
in order to really talk about this we
have to know the reality about some of
these issues like well how many people
really want to come to the u.s and what
is the effect of the immigrant labor
market on wages and
do we need more workers all these
different things okay so in argentina
where i was born
basically the concept of illegal
immigration is it's not really an issue
it's just like if you go and you can
find a job or enroll in school there's
like a path to citizenship for everybody
now why doesn't argentina get overloaded
because the economy is a disaster not
that many people want to go to argentina
okay the united states is a much better
economy than argentina for the average
person
so we often assume
everybody wants to come and move to the
united states and if we just open the
floodgates everybody would
the truth is when you survey people
around the world not that many people
want to move to the united states sure
many do but most people want to be in
the country where they live and where
their family is and when they speak
their language and we're okay so the
first thing is
even if we open the floodgates
completely yes many people would come to
the u.s but it's not the world is going
to come rushing to the u.s so the first
thing we would have to realize is how
many people really want to come here
fine and how many would that be do you
think if you just open borders i don't
remember i'm not an advocate of open
borders anyway but i don't remember what
that what the numbers are it's been a
year since i looked at this data but
when you look at many countries and
it'll be like 10 of a country
might want to come to the u.s maybe a
country with 5 million people so that's
like half a million but then how many
actually would do it well it's a
fraction of that and how many would stay
and it's a fraction of that but so the
first ten percent of most countries in
the world there's quite a lot of people
right i'm making the number up i i'm
just okay okay doesn't matter
i'm not advocating we open the
floodgates anyway there should be an
immigration policy there should be a
process
that's a very right wing david
welcome to the far right the second part
of it would be well what is the effect
of immigrant
documented immigrant and undocumented
immigrant labor on wages because there's
this economic concept where if you
suddenly flood with tons of supply for
something the price demanded will go
down and wages will go down well
remember
we have a minimum wage in the united
states there's ways around it with under
the table work i would concede but there
is there is a minimum wage which is a
different argument that some people are
also against but that is a lower limit
on wages but the truth is that the
studies that have been done
show
that uh
immigrant labor documented and
undocumented in the aggregate has
essentially no statistical effect on
wages now i know it's counterintuitive
because it's like well
if i can find an undocumented immigrant
to work for two bucks an hour which in
theory you can and
it should depress wages but in a country
of 331 million with the number of
immigrants documented and undocumented
that we have
and the fields in which they work and on
and on it has a negligible effect on
wages
much more of an effect on wages is seen
from lack of regulation
on the corporations that are doing the
hiring and in some industries actually
colluding to hold wages down so it's
like okay well that's a piece wages will
collapse
actually they won't so
i'm i'm glad to kind of see where you
want to kind of steer this from here but
i think one of the things that we have
to understand is a lot of the sort of um
common sense about immigration when you
look at it you know immigrants commit
more crime actually immigrants commit
less crime even undocumented immigrants
why because they know they're in the
country illegally
they go out of their way to stay off the
radar of law enforcement makes perfect
sense
once you break all these things down you
know hopefully you can get to a better
place to really talk about this stuff
so what you were saying is essentially
it's control of greater regulations of
corporations that will ensure better
conditions for workers and better pay
that's not what i said what i said is
more responsible for stagnant wages than
immigrant labor
is the way in which corporations can
work in a whole bunch of different ways
to avoid paying more and this includes
that their employees are subsidized by
government programs this includes using
third parties and contractors rather
than employees you know we're again
getting into very specific issues but
all of those things are far more
responsible for stagnant wages than
immigrant labor
okay uh can i can i go to the cultural
side of the immigration conversation
then which is
this won't really apply to the us but
i'll put it on the table just for for
our viewers because you guys you're a
nation of immigrants melting pot all of
that so
you know you have a different view of
immigration generally but particularly
what you call undocumented
immigration what we call illegal
immigration in this country which is
people coming into the country without
following the immigration rules right
is there not a moral argument that that
is just wrong that allowing people to
come to circumvent the cube because i'm
a legal immigrant in the uk right i had
to follow a pretty expensive and pretty
thorough process for this country to
make sure that i meet the requirements
that the people of this country voted to
have in place for who can come and live
here and there are other people who are
getting in a bow and crossing the
english channel or in your case crossing
the rio grande
by paying somebody two thousand dollars
or whatever it is um
to come into the country that this isn't
what we as the people of the united
states or we as the people in the united
kingdom voted for and people who do this
should not be allowed to come and if
they do come they should be sent back
and forced to join the legal process
which we all voted for yeah i mean
listen uh my family came to the united
states legally it was a lottery system
um and uh
we wouldn't have come if we hadn't
gotten it uh i think the
you know countries are allowed it's not
immoral to have a border it's not a
moral to enforce the border
deportation in and of itself is not
something i advocate should end
i think the areas where i have a problem
include
one
uh those who came to the united states
when they were not adults because they
were brought by parents
and their lives are here i don't think
it's fair to send them back to a country
that they may have quite literally no
connection in that doesn't make sense to
me i think if you want to
enforce the border
and it's you have to understand that
two-thirds of it is not literally the
border it's people just coming in and
overstaying visas for example
um and i also think that you have to
concede david i'm sorry to interrupt
this isn't to trip you up at all i
really want to hear the rest of your
answer but just on those people can i
ask you if someone has overstayed the
visa should they be deported
uh yes yeah i mean
i'm open to we have courts that
adjudicate this okay and there are a
number of circumstances where i would
say
individuals should be allowed to stay if
they've
you know if you have someone who's been
here
uh some period of time
and they've committed no crimes and they
are productive members of society and
i'm totally open to immigration judges
saying you get to stay
uh but i am not
the country has a right to enforce
immigration law that's
what it is yeah we have to change the
law if we don't want that yeah sorry for
interrupting i just wanted to clear that
particular point up yeah um no i don't
mean i don't i mean i guess i'm you know
if you if you really want to deal with
this issue
it's not about
a wall on the southern border would be
my point and you also
do yourself if you're better able
to understand how people are coming in
you can
make
unnecessary so much other infrastructure
that's currently in place
so when you say that there are other
ways to solve the problem what is that
well again the the majority of people
are not coming over the border yeah so
you need to deport them we've got that
right
most of them
so the people who are overstaying the
visas unless they've been in the country
for a really long time and the
immigration judge looks at their case
and goes you get to stay cause you're
you know the kind of person we want here
everybody else gets sent back right yeah
i mean you know practically speaking
it's not going to happen because you
know it's just
there's not information about every
single person who's in that case
practically speaking but theoretically
there's no legal case to argue that all
those people get to stay right i think
that if you i'm open to
a path to amnesty
with certain requirements and i think
that what that would be is up for debate
if someone came to me and said okay
listen
um if you've committed no crime other
than being here illegally
and you have employment and whatever
other mechanisms are met you're put on a
seven-year path to citizenship i'm
totally open to things like that but i
think it's a tough argument for me to
make that the current law should just be
ignored
right okay and then what about in terms
of people who do come in illegally over
the border let's say what should happen
to them in in your in an ideal world
we we already it's already happening i
mean they're here illegally so they're
subject to deportation i mean that's
that's that's how it is cool that seems
like a pretty sensible approach that
part of it to me which i think we could
probably agree on um
and and the last uh element because
we've got about five minutes and then we
need to do questions for our local
supporters and we don't want to take up
any more of your time david is what do
we do with with the people
on on the left who
are very loud and for people like me
like just to let you know i'm a former
teacher i talk in the public school
system
that
for many years
and and i see people on the left saying
you know oh you know we need to defund
the police we need to abolish capitalism
and coming from a country like venezuela
i've seen what happens when you abolish
capitalism uh it doesn't end well what
do we do and obviously those people
should be allowed their views
but how do we make the left more
palatable to the ordinary person
and distance itself from those types of
people
because to me most people aren't going
to vote for that yet defunding the
police doesn't pull well among the
democratic party that the people who
support it on twitter are very loud but
we have polling data
just defunding the police isn't super
popular reforming the police and i put
out you know a 10-point plan of how i
would do it is very popular so uh that
was one thing the other thing is most
democrats aren't socialists so i think
the the important thing for me is
i'm not interested in kind of arguing
with straw men and sure there are real
socialists and there are people who say
get rid of the police altogether these
are tiny groups they're not super
interesting to me i'm more interested in
articulating my ideas
okay so let's talk about police
reformation how would you reform the
police in america yeah so um we i mean
it depends on which uh police department
we're talking about there's a big
difference between rural and urban
police departments in the united states
but i think establishing a system for
at minimum
required social work type training for
officers should should be a minimum
requirement i would love to also have
social workers and mental health
professionals who are the first line of
response to certain types of calls if
someone calls because there's
a homeless person panhandling who maybe
is overdosing i don't know that you need
a police officer with a gun to be the
first line of response there or maybe
you send a police officer and a social
worker i think that that would be a
great thing
i think that there should be a national
database of bad actors so when you've
been discharged from your role as an
officer for bad acts it should be easy
if you go to a different state and apply
for the place you're applying to look up
whether you've been whether you've lost
a police job because of bad acts police
unions resist that
the police unions resist that yes yes
they don't want they don't want an such
a national database in the united states
uh that's i think something that would
be important um
i like uh mandatory body cameras as
we've seen
a lot of the devil is in the details
they end up not working at key moments
or the the file gets deleted when you
want to find you know so i i like the
idea of police body cameras you know i
don't remember all of my 10 points i did
this about a couple years ago on my show
but you know these are some of the ideas
now i think it's really important to say
some of the stuff i'm talking about
costs money
and so
in some places the problem is police is
underfunded and so they resort to low
energy policing
which is terrible rather than really
preventing crime or dealing with you
know there's too much of a focus on
street crime in the u.s rather than
white collar and corporate crime some of
this stuff will need more money for
police which is why i think defund as a
catch-all doesn't work david can i just
before we go to our final question and
then the questions from our supporters
first of all again thank you for coming
on i really appreciate donna's
conversation we've had obviously there's
areas of agreement disagreement whatever
but i think this is great please but i
think we kind of we got over france's
point a little bit which i do think is
important because i hear what you say
because i'm the same like i have right
of center views and left of center views
and i find myself embroiled with arguing
with extremists on the right and the
left about stupid [ __ ] and i probably
shouldn't and you're smart not to do
that
with the extremists on your side the
problem i would say to you though is
some of their slogans while not being
popular in terms of how they poll
have filtered through
into mainstream debate and even policy i
mean look at defunding the police we
have seen some cities adopting policies
in america of this type and resulting in
spikes in crime what is that fair to say
uh i'm i i'm not so sure about that who
what who has defunded the police
yeah i i don't remember i remember
reading articles showing spikes in crime
in some cities which have taken a more
sort of let's reduce the amount of
policing we do but i i couldn't give you
a specific example of the top are you
saying that's not happened in any city
in any major i'm not aware of any place
that has
just flatly defunded police eliminated
officers with guns and done whatever not
completely but reduce their involvement
reduce the amount of funding you know we
i have read articles again about uh
places where this the sort of
the environment for police officers is
such that a lot of people take early
retirement or move to another state etc
are you not aware of anything of that
kind i mean listen there's 331 million
people in the u.s i'm sure there are
some police departments who have seen a
decline in funding and we'd have to look
at the reasons and the purpose i i just
without examples it's hard to speak to
it but to get to what i think is your
main question about how to address these
people the way i address it is again if
they want to call into my show and argue
with me i gladly will
if they run for office on some of these
things i don't agree with i don't vote
for them and i tell my audience not to
vote for them the same way i do with any
candidate that i don't agree with and i
try to keep i can't control corporate
media but on my program which i can
control i keep the narrative about what
i think are good ideas
brilliant good answer
david with that thank you so much for
coming on as i say we're going to ask
you a couple of questions from our
supporters for our supporters in a
second but as always our final question
is what is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that you
think we really should be i think that
we could very quickly get completely off
of fossil fuels for transportation
if we really decided as countries as
governments that we're going to do it
and i would like to see that done i've
switched over to an electric vehicle
i've got solar panels on and on and on
and i think that it would be great
economically climate and culturally it
would be a fantastic thing i would love
to see it talked about more
david it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much if people want to find
you online where is the best place to do
that davidpakman.com
and you of course host a very popular
show here on youtube uh thank you so
much for coming on david uh please don't
go anywhere because we're gonna ask you
the couple of questions but with that
thank you for being on the show thank
you guys for watching and listening
we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one or raw
show all of them go out at 7 pm uk time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
what is the most persuasive way of
convincing people who are conservative
at the moment who lean conservative to
your side of the argument
[Music]
you